Es war wirklich einer der spektakulärsten funde der letzten jahre die mumie eines wesens das tatsächlich ziemlich
So aussah wie wir uns in unserer phantasie ein alien vorstellen der riesige kopf der lange schmale körper
Sollten die mediendarstellung also doch der realität entsprechen
Vor 15 jahren wurde die mumie in einer verlassenen stadt in der atacama wüste in chile
Gefunden was ist also mit der endung mobi auf sich hat jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Das war schon der aktion spektakulärer fund vor 15 jahren in der kleinen verlassenen stadt la noria in der atacama wüste in chile
Die trockenste wüste der welt die mumie war extrem klein hatte aber die
Proportionen eines erwachsenen es war eine absolute sensation doch zu einer
wissenschaftlichen untersuchung kam es nie schon kurz nach der entdeckung wurde die mumie verkauft und entzog sich damit einer genaueren
extrahierung doch irgendwann landete die mumie auf einem info logan congress in barcelona
Und kam damit zumindest ihnen die nähe von wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftlern ein team um gary nordin untersucht die die mobilen dann
2013 zum ersten mal vor fünf jahren begann er dann die dna
sequenzierung und das ergebnis war dann einerseits erwartet aber auch ein bisschen seltsam das erbgut war zu 91%
menschlich der rest war durch die verwesung zerstört worden und überrascht war das forschungsteam vom zustand der knochen
Demnach lebte dieses kind nämlich und wurde sogar sechs oder sieben jahre alt war sehr seltsam jetzt hat das forschungsteam
seinen abschlussbericht vorgelegt und muss ich korrigieren
Demnach war die mumie wohl doch ein frühchen das aufgrund zahlreicher genetische veränderung nicht lebensfähig war es war
Kleinwüchsig hatte eine skoliose also eine verkrümmung der wirbelsäule und noch andere fehlbildungen der muskeln und knochen und schwere
stoffwechselerkrankungen haben wohl zu der falschen analyse der knochen geführt jetzt
ist klar das kind starb vor der geburt als fotos dass diese erkenntnisse jetzt alle so gut
Erzielt werden von lag vor allem am fundort in der trockenste wüste der welt wurde die leiche
Besonders gut konserviert werden als erstes neues zu solchen themen erfahren wollt
dann
Endet meine telefonnummer whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion vom klicks und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was ja bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken aliens können wir sie leichter finden ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran